brought to you by farcry for pre-order
now for a free limited edition upgrade
coming November 18th
hello everybody welcome back to another
episode of top 5 scary months of the
week I'm cam Robinson this is Seb Ford
and we have returned against all odds
yeah they didn't say anything so well
y'all thought we were dead yep we're
back we we were allowed back in the
country you got to customs and they were
like alright we've heard you guys need
to produce some or Skyrim so when you
come on through I mean say we do have a
whole lot of drugs in your bag but then
Skyrim mods matter so on you go with
weapons this year website but we've been
away at e3 have we've missed exactly two
episodes we apologize you see but this
one is going to be multiple times better
to make up for the absence
how many multiple times at least twice
maybe thrice but no more than that
certainly no no four times around I good
quick we'll do this for you mostly must
be
all right so time for the first mod of
this week which is Skyrim Stargate mod
so SEP did you watch scarp this scar
gate it's a famous film over there was
the follow-up to Scarface yes yes the
one they set in space yes well he was
huffing space cocaine
did you watch Stargate as you did this
mod it also has everything to do with
not quite what no oh oh God wolves any
weakness how did that even happen
so interests um this mod starts off a
bit broken as you can tell I can tell
them what's going on here why is it why
is it what so let's go to the general's
office okay okay man you could you could
submit letter skip the lift right double
time the left speed I think right here
we are my office eventually step into my
office
yes yeah whatever who I think we should
do this whole ever no idea what they did
oh wait wait wait that seems to that
start oh there it is Seb it's the start
like a Stargate ah
lightning distribution 3 to this power
symbol 1 equals 1 2 articles to that's
fine you a curious I do it lover I don't
know I do pull them all flipping the
whole mall says I push the button died
up absolutely not that didn't work
oh wait here we go oh wow there's more
team up we have even coded some stuff
see that
yeah not all know like hey what looks
kinda cool slide very clever very clever
system Wow
all right I want to choose Seb try good
e0 yes like we have we have gates yeah
see I see stars it wasn't it wasn't
particularly dramatic but it's it's
there that was definitely some Stargate
all right said I like the the sound
effects of absolutely not nothing yeah
gonna put my torch away you don't need a
torch in Stargate you might need a sword
though definitely need a sword are you
ready to cross the event horizon we do
have a time limit on this of one minute
all right let's do it that's it and
that's taken us to here and here we are
where where is here this is called the
warehouse Stargate oh wow it feels kind
of cool it's got a different coordinate
god this is so much easier look at this
Oh
spinny dials and star like that what and
a button midair and a floating air
button and some stuff yeah and some NPCs
no you are killable oh yes okay I three
rings
hahahahaha awesome
did it work yeah that's how you get
around DM it just took us up from there
to here
okay let's say you get read the pyramids
remember I do remember but that doesn't
seem very useful I mean it's done really
well it technically transported us from
here to there yeah eat your heart out
Jeff Goldblum
come on Johnny char all right John each
other this is totally gonna what I have
you travel Oh Oh got him a little bit
come on Johnny char come on no got it
ah just hates corpses Oh awesome
that's a cool apparently all of these
are the star signs in the games well I
bet they are yeah
no it's not that yes it is oh it is oh
my god thank you worked I'm worried now
because this is open we've activated it
what if like bad guys come through we're
not close the iris how do you close the
iris where's the iris button I don't
think there is an iris oh god I think
we're just doomed forever where we can
get some weapons but we should do in
fact said I think we have mod number
two's gonna do exactly that for us give
us some Stargate weapons let's do it all
right said mod number two is here and
actually technically it's two mods it's
your fire staff and zat gun mod
tool Kevin up to fight off anyone who
comes through the Stargate now you can
Smith these weapons as you know as you
could famously in the show if you see
the show go guys were low on weapons
good thing there's a forge yep so
there's a staff yeah yellow buddies
right
the original Mac talk the Jafar weapon
of Stargate sj1 sj2 che oh my god I met
that that was Star Wars sj2 and then we
have the zat gun Jafar weapon of
Stargate sg-1 we're gonna sink her
Russell through he's the only one he
knows what he's doing it's like I've
been actor right so stop first step
let's see it okay well it doesn't seem
to appear on you
okay okay ah ah alright let's have a
what should we SAP okay see no crosshair
so this could be tricky yep dialing it
in sep damning it in when you like pull
the trigger to start charging up yeah it
makes the sound of the that the head of
the weapon opening oh yeah I like that
get shots not very strong no in the show
bit of a one-hit killer that it is and
they just vaporize them yeah yeah like
that
nice work Kevin one hit for stun two
hits for kill three hits completely
disintegrates the body is that right is
that right yes I'm gonna say it's right
oh that was cool
oh god it's hard to hit oh it's really
hard to hit when you go on rubbish oh
you got him whoa that's strong oh wow
it's really strong uh kit hit him again
I want to see if it does atomized his
body
I would have gained a nice touch if
you're listening pockets right I'm just
gonna suggest maybe as a laugh you might
want to think about making it do that
cuz that'd be very cool what if he
happens if he's that gonna care how
could that ever happen show cow whoa
where did he go wow that was pretty
impressive that's weapon ever but your
cab deposit this is the best weapon hold
still guys whoa that's amazing
this is wicked love this weapon oh okay
okay okay okay I see your arrows sir Oh
drains their life and the students are
dead then launches them hey pal
Oh graceful beast is my keys all right
let's see it whoa again I think he's
playing are you playing pal you're only
scratch your tummy oh my god I just ran
through him him again it's quite good
for like nudging things either fox8 box
a oh so close
hold still you can get launched it all
that was just quite sad foxes are
naturally immune weapons of course yes
oh god don't know
saber can't Winston he's my son first ah
he's gonna die for this was great that
wow that was a stunning shot say I love
this weapon I this is gonna become a
permanent fixture of kevin van doors are
still good
okay so that was some good stargazing
but it's time to move on to some non
Stargate mods and do you like goggles
and monocle set they are my two favorite
things in life gonna love this mod hope
summer goggles and Scouter ooh now I
think we tried to craft these but we
couldn't find them so instead we use
console commands let's just wear them
and square them they said would you want
to choose when you equip you get night I
detect life light or off off sounds
boring I I like the idea let's just try
light let's go let's go Jen Tevan though
it's daylight outside oh that's awesome
so is that casting actual light I think
it's just lighting his beautiful face I
think he just makes him visible to all
Yannick says definitely lay is true I
think it's just much the same as a torch
you know like lights of the immediate
area around you all right the idea that
to Weimar might actually have something
like yeah let's try a let's try again
throw to our goggles and let's do night
I that sounds like it like okay night I
activated is it is it is it really try
the skater let's try the web recites
yeah go for it oh wow so uh corpses
flash naturally it seems we are stuck
with there the light being on though and
there's something a living equals yellow
that's pretty great actually so it's
like a cake life spell but also shows up
items and thinks about skeleton yeah so
the reason the more craters made this is
because armor in anything that you wear
doesn't run out over time like any
effects that you have is constant so
what he did was he wanted to have Dwemer
stuff that's charged up by using Dwemer
you know 12 an oil is she a reason for
that stuff man yeah so as you walk
around using all of the tools that this
has it will learn it will use up to oven
oil and so you'll need to top it up as
you go goggles on head / over eyes so if
we were hit n on we're wearing the
goggles he would he like pop them up
onto the top of his head you want me to
find out need the oil levels are 22
there
and tech life is definitely activated
there you go
yep there now on his head and again
wipes and down into his face nice threat
assess I want threat assess let's try
threats
oh there's a threat there's a threat
that sounds like a threat I've heard
threats before assess his threat oh yeah
red ah don't be threatening definitely
big threat assess this your day also
activate detect live from recite so you
could have it so the auto activate a
thing when you put them on hmm or while
weapon is drawn awhile story while
sneaking or while the weapon is drawn
that's cool see like oh you know every
time I sneak I want threat assess to go
on yeah that's pretty cool
December not another awesome thing is if
you click the mouse wheel in and you got
the goggles are the first person you get
the zoom nice awesome very layer you see
like what is that yellow thing over
there oh wait oh that's a fire it's
definitely if I am easy no problem
pretty great what it was red oh your
dress goggles need oiling oh no what
zoom it turns out uses a lot of oil yeah
it definitely does didn't realize that
famous here I beg you'll find some oil
okay sometime for the fourth mod of
today and you know what we just don't
have enough traps in Skyrim fortunately
this mod is called deployable trap
perfect just what we need and we can
Smith them if I'd and you can't to it
any Forge across the land of Skyrim aha
loads of different things so we need two
ingredients before we can make all these
throws let's do that alright step so
we've made a bunch of traps let's place
them on the road here and then encourage
some mare unlucky people to run over
them well if we're going with run over
then I think we should start with the
caltrops okay so I think we just dropped
these so yeah they're not in your
weapons are just in your misc hmm so
caltrop sees it works by by dropping
them individually yes there's that
there you go very good she gets him
again what happens if I run over them oh
they hurt me
yes they cause me pain oh I think we're
gonna have a dragon room don't worry
they hate caltrops quick let me go lure
them over the caltrops
don't follow me oh yeah wow they're
really good
hahaha come and get me lazarey's
probably can't can't quite get me Oh God
oh no today I figured out a way through
pink those just bear traps I don't care
I want to see it I want to see it
come on whatever this guy needs alright
we need to throw something else down for
this guy he's gonna be problematic yeah
uh-oh
Dwayne my battery okay now he's not
gonna blow up on its own or am i have to
shoot that would you say - rolling
downhill away from everybody let's
quickly shoot it before it get lost
everyone quick give me a mic in my bow
why he just killed himself in the
character opps well that was that was
useless right that battery's as much
he's in the drink now alright I've got a
bad plan let's let's do something else
let's let's get a boulder and roll it
there towards them yes heavy Boulder how
many just one just the one alright
gravity go away wow that Boulder did
like nothing I don't quite understand
the Boulder one we just like they
bounced off them yeah okay that should
have crushed them to death nevermind
let's try liquid ice shoot that up oh
god it's going reading a football well
that worked that definitely worked
nothing worked will one set off another
like in a wonderful chain reaction chain
reaction of pain I hope so
oh they're all flu so they're a curious
little floating thing going on Chester I
wonder if that's part of them a strap or
regular trap well being right at while
floating traps like oh I died oh you got
away
Wow whoops whoops well I think we got an
army to a question we did a thing one
will set off another I don't know what
both she's running away I don't blame
her let's measure we just blew his shirt
off that's impressing we did let's do
the compressed gas on its own
that was the gas Oh gases in like poison
poison gas aah
however oh he's getting up you don't
always get down okay hold on we got we
got more bandits going on over there
more bandits they say hey guard
no no no don't you go anywhere hey whoa
it's like it's like a shout it's awesome
yeah that one's powerful okay service
time for the final mod no because our
first modules are user booty this one is
just a wreck site is but a silly fun one
what is it said this one is called no
one cares about Nazim and it was
recommended to us by mark bacon on
Twitter so uh thanks mark
everyone else in Whiterun lovely
friendly inviting you to join the
companions making you a yell or rather
the other thing chanting at you or young
a cow but Nazim he's only a scene was
just a stunning jerk where is he do you
get to the cloud district very often so
here is court and he's being mean being
a jerk
hey Nazim oh it took years but I earned
my way to the top I own cheerful farm
you see very successful
this obvious right so these are the
reasons why maybe we hate this guy yeah
oh yeah let's see bit of a stunning
judge what does this mod do exactly sir
I'd love to tell you that cam no one
cares about Nazim what it does says
guards ignore assaults on the xeam good
town's folk may say insulting things to
Nazim many of white runs inhabitants
have rival relationships with him he's a
coward now you can pickpocket and
assault and you can also marry his wife
all wonderful this pickpocketing phone
right in front of that guard yep they
don't care although he is a coward and
he's not running away oh dear I think I
forgot kevin von euch left hook kills a
man killed damn shame shame put him in
the world coz that's where he does
that's where he belongs
well you just get on the well Nazim for
once in your life do you get to the well
district often Nazim no of course you
don't
where is Nazim wife and how do I marry I
need something yeah what your wife
please yes yes yes just go and stroll
past your dead body let's try again then
she isn't dead buddy what happened that
guy looks just like me it's know what to
think he's really shaken up let's say
let's do some couch all day while he's
shopping ha ha they'll never escape what
if we were to shoot all of the things he
could buy so that he has no choices left
ok nope Oh guys whoopsie-daisy good you
know one the seams annoying or annoying
do you think whether all these corpses
of mine come from how about 10 disease
and then and then I know they're all
running into a culture I'm citing each
other more than other again killer
burger chops
amazing amazing
back so if we had caltrops all over the
floor and then chickens I'll be
brilliant are they just gonna set
themselves off oh maybe we're going to
find out I guess is this just gonna
prepare yourself this my team an
imminent explosion immediate exposure
game ok eighty chicken ok on the count
you weren't wrong Sam you were wrong
called it totally cool lady's name wow
what have we done I think we blow
ourselves out of why one we really did
that's probably what happened yeah
something to happen
not quite we've come quite a distance
but it was like a weird one to finish on
but but you know I thought maybe because
we didn't have the user voted model ass
that it was it was a good one to go and
we didn't have time to marry his wife no
I'm sorry that's a final insult when
slowing him up were killed and 50 times
you get then of course Mary's wife as
any normal person would yes but we've
got the questions now yeah we haven't
any questions we've had Lord build-up
have be able to like ask them for ages
so Seb you've picked some doozies as we
found just heaven this first one is for
you amazing that's my seat ready [__]
is Scott Adam McNee would like to know
okay Adam can you review a Scottish mod
ie a kilt mode please kill me
I believe kilt mode is the disguise
pronounced nation mod yeah yeah I don't
know I don't think they exist I've lit I
could have definitely looked in the past
I'm not yeah I know right if I read like
every morning search history I guess
Maude I guess my kill mod this Zealand
mud there's some words already thistles
in the game cap I know but I won't wanna
thistle eat thistle yeah okay anyway I
will have a look
we will keep looking it's all about with
the awesome well considering so many
people made battle axes of hatred for us
yes I'll make some black hills of hatred
I'd be great make a kilt for Kevin van
Nord a wild haggis for him to hunt and
be amazing
to chase down with his fists yeah Cammy
you like to take the next one I would
love to you this is from Jack Hodgkinson
and he says I didn't think of a penis
until he pointed it out and and then Sir
Adrian says Seb has such a dirty mind
okay and that was in roses
that was his sanity is there evil armor
hours with Kevin van org course I've
evil armor had a sword which I think I
think had quite a phallic weapon it was
it was I would agree it would agree I
stand by that I'm glad that since I
pointed it out everyone can now see it
and the next comment Seb is actually a
picture and a song that we were involved
in so when we're at e3 yeah we actually
got recognized by a skyrim Oz fan you
did you did well no we were both on we
both on the ask my god chords in the
gravity of your recognition
weird because like because obviously I
don't ever get recognized so I was on
the elevator and this girl looked up and
like smiled and waved therefore I seemed
I must have known her yeah it's not mine
no I go to another fan I was like I must
know this person so I like to wave back
and then I start lead unto me I have no
idea who this person is which was kind
of awkward and then they were lovely and
it was there when he was Randy Radley
Tolbert and and she was look she's
wearing a skirt just happened to
worrying it happens oh yeah skyrim fan
Randy Tolbert thank you so much mater
dad told a lie to us we told everybody
yes we arrest everyone everyone got
really sick of the story
it was great mate was great it was great
and the next one is from a Beck steel
Templar who after we requested it can
wear nowhere meme oh yeah yeah dinner
she go and have a go at it
it's Kevin Otis so tough Chuck Norris
says damn which is you know it's fair
enough yeah fair enough
alright so if anyone else wants to have
a swing at making the Kevin Brad gnawed
me which by the way Kevin bana bleep
meme minute of meep meep meep is another
enzyme just I'm dieting your accent okay
okay sorry a meme meme yeah if anyone
would like to have another guy making
that but it is something that Kevin man
odd oh yeah thumbs Gavin yeah came up
but yeah that was that was the one and
only attempt so thank you tough uh else
we go why don't you take this okay this
is from man really not crispy crispy
nuts Dana yeah as Elder Scrolls 6 is
probably in the works and I'll say them
cancelling the series good points what
kind of feature would you like to see in
the future games that we currently get
from mods are good question also what
kind of technology should be built into
eight models in the future that is a
very good double barrelled great first
question let's pick a motto I mean I
would really love to see and then else
grow six a bit of a combat overhaul then
we have we've showcased a couple of
combat overhauls on the show before it's
been a while since we don't want there
was one that was quite good that can a
realistic was all more about blocking
was absolutely key I like it took down
your stamina I'd like to see a bit more
maybe not too complicated but combat and
Skyrim is probably the weakest part of
it yeah I would say anyway so maybe that
I think I think that they could have
made better use of the Dwemer group you
know as you know I don't like them
because I think they're boring so and so
many mods have done things like maybes
like
where my shields are all mechanized
remember the exascale the exoskeleton
was incredible
so I think using you know taking some of
the ideas that have been made from there
and feeding them into the the gameplay
in a grander sense good cool stuff with
that but in terms of like modding tools
or we don't mod so it's hard to really
say but I mean certainly seems to be
pretty open like people hope to make
some really crazy stuff may it be good
for them to include just a ton more
animations because that is often like I
think they're an idiot factor I mean you
can't make your own animations yeah it's
good thing it's a lot more common
include the script ins extender in by
default oh yeah yeah point there you go
so you can you can get more controls
over things like key presses you're
watching Todd Howard I know you are cuz
you always do every week yes there is
your recommendations Oh cut that was in
reference to the edit I definitely
didn't just make this thing order yes
are you going all right it's time to say
definitely time for the road not another
question that I started we do rusty
we've got Russell we're so out of
practice with this day all right let's
just cruise on through it and there here
are the mods that you can put for and we
have to include one of these of course
next week mm-hmm Sam what's the first
mode up for the book first one is armor
of the valerian Crusader let's first
talk about this when I was like ooh
valerian is this they're just getting
Game of Thrones II bit Alex almost a bit
more lords of Rings II Lord of rings II
instead of Game of Thrones yep next one
is become y'all of IVA said and us we've
actually had this one suggestively time
so I I really wanted to get none and
then and ethereal century and wormer
great sword
another Dwemer mod for you sir yeah I
have humming around to the as mods I'm
reporting an excellent yeah and where
could they go to poke first asks well
said they should go to tinyurl.com
forward slash ready savvy blog mmm okay
and I can update cuz I've left that blog
unchecked and unadjusted
for two weeks you knows what's growing
well I'm gonna see what I left it with
it was the opening monologue of Romeo
and Juliet as modified by this guy
how drunk were you I was quite far gone
and very jet-lagged okay so I'm gonna
blame that but yes head over to
tinyurl.com forward slash ready savvy
blog and there'll be a new vote link
there and
pick ya favorite you know what if you
don't like any of those munchies like
those mods are rubbish I have loads of
great suggestions well you can suggest
them to us anytime you want by getting
in touch over Twitter I am at kam fries
Rob yeah he's at ready semi go oh and
you can use our hashtag Gaea Skyrim
either way one of those ways we'll get
that suggestion and we include like
almost all of them end the show all the
good ones we do liked it we skimmed
through the you know the the YouTube
comments yeah and the and the GameSpot
comments but there are so many of them
we often miss all of the mod suggestions
in there so Twitter is definitely the
easiest way to guarantee the wheel
Belkis seem hard cut Seb do you like
watching me
I sure do cam that's wierd sure do if
you guys like watching me you can watch
my other show reality check
it's a science he show doesn't really
involve Skyrim but last week I analyzed
reverse speech to get secrets out of e3
conference and this week we're gonna be
weaponizing animals so on Thursday and
any time after that obviously you can go
to gamespot.com
and watch reality check you should do it
yes fun please come watch my show you
should also check out not cam as well
you should go and check out a Jess on
the gist if you haven't been watching
that because a great show next week
she's going to be all runnel it this
week hard cuts ya know we've used up our
- hard cuts oh no ya know I gotta keep
going with it buttons fallen off the
haircut machine keep going this week
she's gonna be checking out the four
craziest bad guys in game so number one
Kevin van org number two Kevin van Nord
Kevin by odd van or yeah they're all in
there and nord again for the fourth but
yeah be sure to go and check that out as
well the good news is sab is we are done
with hiatus ease cc's we'll be back next
week for more top 5 scary modes of the
week apologies for those two weeks break
let us know what you did did you just
play a lot of Skyrim did you make your
own mod show did you see this guy on the
stage it Evi on the stage at e3 did you
see this guy you wouldn't cuz he was
controlling this I was busy falling off
the stage and I genuinely have to go to
the doctor later Brooke Weldon breakers
what do you do your leg bruised it
heavily I I don't know we'll find out
variation will Steph still be able to
walk find out next week on top 5 scary
months of the week
brought to you by farcry for pre-order
now for a free limited edition upgrade
coming November 18th